Lauren Malaysia's anti-corruption
Commission has released a series of
audio recordings featuring former Prime
Minister Najib Razak seeking help from
Abu Dhabi's Crown Prince to conceal a
deal linked to the 1mdb corruption
scandal in one recording asks the Crown
Prince to help his son we need to
Michael Hirsh - president and CEO at the
Fairfax group that specializes in
corporate risk management he joins us
now via Skype from the u.s. state of
Florida good to have you with us mr.
ershon well this is explosive stuff what
do you make of it well it really is
extraordinary and it came out of left
field as you may know the trial has been
ongoing in Malaysia many documents have
been entered into evidence many
statements taken many witnesses called
but no one expected to uncover these
sorts of taped conversations between the
highest Ben officials in two
jurisdictions a jeep faces what 42
criminal charges in five separate trials
related to the alleged theft of billions
of dollars from
MDB he's the subject of investigations
in at least six countries including the
US Singapore and Switzerland
is he going to be held to account is he
guilty well it remains to be seen as to
whether he will be found guilty but I
see the evidence as overwhelming and I
do believe he will be held to count
others have already been held to account
as you know there have been several
convictions on this case stemming from
the theft one of the largest thefts in
the history of governmental corruption
what about the legality of these
recordings they were made while he was
still the head of government well we
don't know who made them we don't know
whether they were made for example by
the intelligence services of Malaysia or
they were provided by someone on the
other end of the conversation in the UAE
regardless of whether they are found to
be admissible into evidence they show a
pattern of misconduct a pattern of
cover-up which is a model for what not
to do in 2015 I specifically called on
Najib to come clean to admit what he's
been involved in and to apologize and
seek for forgiveness he chose a
different path he chose a path of
coverup and frankly this is one of the
worst cover-up situations that I've run
into in the course of the many
investigations I've done over the years
you had a direct involvement in this
matter which until now has been has
never been disclosed he are you willing
to disclose that to us now I'd be happy
to in 2015 the Malaysian anti-corruption
Commission the MACC under the chief
commissioner at that time Abu Cosima
haben was investigating the prime
minister for money laundering and
misconduct at that time the chief
commissioner Abu Kasim Mohamed
then Attorney General and told the
Attorney General of Malaysia that the
Prime Minister was a target of their
investigation when the Attorney General
confronted the Prime Minister and told
him he was on the criminal investigation
he was forced out of office and replaced
by a friend of Najib's at the same time
Abu Kassim Mohammed was placed under
surveillance this is the chief
commissioner and was asked to resign
from office was pressured to resign from
office was at that point when Abu who
I've known for many years he and I
served together on an Interpol
anti-corruption Commission asked if I
would pass on documents to the u.s.
prosecution authorities in New York the
US Attorney's Office and to arraign for
a secret meeting with him with the US
Attorney's Office so that he could be
assured that an entity outside of
Malaysia would continue this
investigation I did provide that
information I did set up that meeting
unfortunately as a result he was faced
with charges of treason for assisting a
foreign prosecution Authority in its
investigation of the 1mdb scandal mr.
Harshman really appreciate you being
with us many thanks indeed